tomorrow marks 100 years since President
Woodrow Wilson vetoed the Volstead Act
just one day later on October 28th 1919
the House and Senate overrode that veto
and America suddenly had a law to
enforce prohibition the legacy of
prohibition which lasted 14 years is a
huge part of our nation's history but
there are parts that sometimes get
overlooked or ignored for example who
was Andrew Volstead the author of the
act and what parts of America did
prohibition creates that still exists
today the stars of prohibition have been
glamorized for the last 100 years Al
Capone and her Chicago Court at height
of his career and leaves still king of
bootleggers gangsters like Al Capone
Meyer Lansky and Bugsy Siegel
speakeasies that popped up across the
country allowing people to flout the
nation's new absolutist approach
there's bootleg liquor on every American
lip shiny flask on every hip but the
people in places that still thrive in
movies in pop culture are only part of
the story 100 years later what do people
not understand about Prohibition I think
what people don't understand about
prohibition is the very serious and long
lasting legacies of the law lissa mugger
is a history professor at Harvard
University and the author of the war on
alcohol the 1920s saw a vast upsurge in
federal power and after 1933 that power
did not diminish it simply took on new
directions one of those directions was
policing and surveillance the prison
industry vastly expanded so many of the
kind of legacies that we live with were
established during Prohibition America's
new look and the rise of a large
government was born perhaps more than
anywhere else inside a small town the
modest wood frame home where congressman
Andrew Volstead lived did the man who
banned alcohol in the u.s. drink yes
Melanie Gabbard Gatchell is a historian
at the Andrew J Volstead house and
Museum in Granite Falls Minnesota
you'd be surprised so many people that
come here aren't aware of who he is they
just go ah he's a guy that didn't like
alcohol because people know what
prohibition is they don't know who
Andrew Volstead was yes they hear how
it's the hundredth anniversary but they
don't know the man behind it Andrew
Volstead and other social progressives
felt the country was being ruined by its
saloon culture bars they felt allowed
men to drink their paychecks away while
the family suffered and in some cases
was abused at home
right away he felt very strongly that
morality could be legislated yes he said
they've been legislating morality since
yes the Bible since the Bible and he
figured what's one here's another law
you guys should follow it progressives
in favor of prohibition were joined by a
fervent group of social conservatives
also worried about the country's
direction remember this is a period
where we have between 1880 and 1920 over
20 million immigrants entering the
country and so there's tremendous
anxiety among Protestant middle-class
men and women over how those immigrants
are changing the face of the nation
including their leisure and drinking
habits
despite its expanding power the federal
government struggled to enforce
prohibition which led to unwelcome
opportunities for others the Ku Klux
Klan recruited during the 1920s
instrumentalizing the Volstead Act and
arguing if the federal government the
state and your local police are not able
to rein in violations we will he was the
most hated man in America yes he did not
look like a sympathetic character no one
worked against it really didn't Andrew
Volstead became the face of most
everything that was going wrong he
didn't take into account people's
personal demons their personal
addictions
he didn't take into account that there
always generally seems to be a problem
when the government tries to tinker with
people's personal choices yes exactly
you know because there you're taking
away people's rights to actually decide
for themselves Melanie Gabbard Gatchell
believes Volstead was well intended and
she continues to share his story today
just as Lisa Macker educates on the
wider long-lasting impact of the 18th
amendment was any part of prohibition a
success it is known that in the wake of
the law consumption seemed to have
decline after prohibition the level of
consumption declined by about 30 percent
from what it was in about 1914 you could
say that was a positive impact
prohibition is repealed beyond that
mcgerr says before prohibition saloons
were basically men
bars that emerged after welcomed
everyone it's the moment where women
really come out in a large way in new
spaces and creates essentially the kind
of social form of leisure we've known
ever since the world we live in today
yes exactly
you normally have cocktails at 8:30
builders have our coffees here like know
how much of that what's so interesting
is though that women largely put the
Volstead Bolstad Act into law and and
yet the flip side of it was the bar see
yeah it was this odd combination of
social progressives and conservatives
who came together to push for
prohibition now on the timeline is so
basically 18th amendment only 111 words
the Volstead Act what would codified it
and executed right the 18th amendment
the Volstead Act was 25 pages long and
the reason why they picked Andrew
Volstead in part was because he was such
a good law writer which is why it lasted
for as long as it did last and again
it's legacy continues today amazing that
they were able to pull this over yeah
well and it was lasted for 14 years